so researchers in Sydney looked at the
age and cause of death for a thousand
people in the New York Times obituaries
between 2009 and 2011 and let's take a
look at some of this stuff the national
average age of death for 2010 was
seventy eight point seven years the
average age of death for performers and
athletes about a year and a half what
last seventy seven point two and the
average age of death of business people
83 years so they say love what you do
everybody says that love what you do
that is the key to happiness but
apparently not the key to this stereo
aren't like high-powered businessmen
full of stress and heart attacks and
they drink yeah to perform so even
though they're not famous they're still
accountable yeah so I would think that
surprised me that number and again
they're just numbers that somebody is
showing me so I mean even though it's
statistical I right I mean it's not well
clearly it's not it's not a perfectly
scientific study because it's obituaries
that were in the New York Times which
you're probably is a probably certain
subset of people but we're all
performers we're all big stars do you
fear that you are B do you fear that
you're gonna lose a couple years off
your life because of the crazy lifestyle
is I'm still alive right now I don't
know I always thought if it's in the
cards that I'm gonna be extremely rich
and successful I hope I live to be a
hundred so I can just sit there and
enjoy it at a pool and drinking all day
yeah
so we're people that are following our
dream to doing what we want to do so you
think that that leads itself to a
healthy lifestyle that's what everyone
says if you're if you're living in the
moment and all that kind of stuff and
hopefully you have some money and you're
successful but you think that these
business people are just going to drop
dead because they're not happy and yet
we're finding out it's the complete
reverse of that well they're working
I mean sometimes we're working not at
all for a week and they're working 20
hours a day yeah and sleeping for two
hours a night like it doesn't make any
sense to me so is the point you're
damned if you do and damned if you don't
the point is I'm getting a new job you
want to be a high-powered corporate
executive I can see myself working for a
brand yeah know what comedians do what
could we do we could be in a think tank
of like advertise like we're good with
words right like slogans where do you
ever think like if we're slightly
off-topic here well let's run with it
that if the world ended would there be
anyone less useful than a comedian every
time I'm watching Walking Dead and I'm
thinking these people all have certain
skills the guy with the you know the guy
can shoot a bow and everybody and I can
all do things someone can you know rig a
car I'm like I really can't do much of
it I would have another talk about it
I'm not much I know to forge through a
vending machine and a minibar exactly no
but honestly I think we're leaders and
that if we can calm down the masses are
amongst the chaos that maybe we would
people wouldn't die of fear make less of
the fear right yeah that's a great skill
yeah yeah do you guys think that maybe
the day of the celebrity sort of
dropping dead early usually because of
drug use you know there's a they call it
the 27 club where you've got Jimi
Hendrix Janis Joplin Jim Morrison Kurt
Cobain Amy Winehouse they all died at 27
that seems to be phasing out a little
bit I mean Amy Winehouse was a couple
years ago now right because people are
more aware and I guess it's harder to
hide all the addictions because there's
pictures of everybody so that's kind of
good right it's the world has become CSI
universe then I mean just even from both
the Boston event yeah they found them
because there were cameras right
somewhere so like I feel like everywhere
I go no matter what I'm doing
I might be seen and that causes you to
not be a
recluse drug addict or doing nefarious
things yeah I mean miss you're careful
if you are Yeah right or I'm on dr. Drew
but yeah I think there's more of a
community watching the person
self-destruct yeah I think there's more
of it
it's like talking about you know these
generalizer this these young girls that
get famous fast and get out of control
because they don't really get to grow up
on their own they get to grow up with
everyone watching them yeah yeah where
everything you do is is on Twitter on
Facebook or on television or TMZ or
whatever it's like you don't there's no
way to be safe in that way so you have
to be a little bit more responsible for
your actions to some regard or someone's
gonna throw you in rehab instead rather
than just like put you at the Chateau
Marmont let you waste away yeah do you
think we have any responsibility these
people like amanda Bynes is the perfect
example the girls clearly going off the
deep end right now she's heading in that
Lindsay Lohan Road do we have any Chris
Farley Christian Chris Farley's another
one I miss that guy but yeah I mean do
we have any responsibility when we're
now watching this happen cuz I guess
that's the point social media is
changing where we're literally every day
if you want to see what amanda Bynes is
done to go down that road a little more
you can see it and one day the roads
just gonna end well watching is she
still gonna do it if you don't have an
audience you're still gonna perform yeah
I mean it's give or take I guess but I
don't I don't know are we responsible
man what can I don't know there are
things I guess you can do and you can
try and you know if you know her
personally perhaps I'm generalizing with
amanda Bynes maybe step in but in the
meantime they're still adults that are
making adult choices whether they're
right or wrong so what do we have to do
I think dr. Phil should step in he did
Britney yeah please dr. Phil the last
time he stepped in I think it was with
that guy remember the golden voice guy
yes and then you know there was this
homeless guy that they found on the
street and he had this incredible
announcers voice and dr. Phil stepped in
kind of cleaned him up two days later
the guys like he was beating his wife
again and he was drugs but he does have
a craft Mack
and cheese all right you did a voiceover
I can say for myself
yeah maybe bonobos comm is the official
outfitter of the Reuben report use code
TR r20 for 20% off your first purchase